car new york paris en trois heures et
demie c'est fini le concorde tira delta
s'est posé en fin d'après midi à
l'aéroport de roissy
la belle aventure supersonique se
termine devant le siège d'air france ils
sont nombreux petits et grands à vouloir
rendre un dernier hommage au
supersonique et à ses équipages
amiens - et le dernier vol zurich
salaires il est 18h le concorde apparaît
en bout de piste entouré d'une escouade
de véhicules le drôle d'oiseau blanc
s'arrête devant le personnel de la
compagnie
il salue avec son bec particuliers soit
et reste aujourd'hui qu'il avait une
exaction c'était merveilleux
ça rappelle beaucoup de très très beaux
souvenirs fait et c'est difficile de
devoir partir disant ma ville navigante
sur cet avion comme ça il est 18h30 un
autre concorde traversent le ciel de
roissy le fox bravo achève sa boucle il
a emmené une centaine de passagers pour
un tour à mach 2 contres avec le temps
aujourd'hui il est encore présent bien
présent puisqu'on voit la banque va se
poser
ça sera dans quelques temps je pense
qu'il y aura vraiment le manque qui va
s'installer
c'est toujours très émouvant de voir
partir en avion pourquoi parce qu'un
avion on s'identifie d'abord pour le
travail mais également un avion je
dirais que c'est le transport de nos
rêves adam france concorde me déchirera
bientôt plus le ciel mais les
inconsolables pourront lui rendre un
dernier hommage au musée